ça fait vraiment avec tout ça réveille à
mon tournoi rend notre grille même du
marron c'est super joli écharpe colorée
bijoux de créateur ou épiceries fines
chez dominique en ressort rarement les
mains vides
même quand on n'a pas trop d'idées c'est
la saint-valentin donc un petit cadeau
pour ma femme ça fait deux ans que je
travaille sur le coin donc c'est à côté
du boulot ces pratiques
je trouve toujours quelque chose
difficile de ne pas trouver son bonheur
parmi les 70 fournisseurs qui se trouve
dans la boutique
dominique a monté son affaire il ya dix
ans une consécration cette année fin
janvier elle a reçu le trophée de la
nuit de la déco on a fait beaucoup de
buzz on a fait beaucoup d'animations
c'est sur plusieurs jours moi j'ai
choisi de faire une soirée une soirée
complète jusque minuit mais avec de
nombreuses animations
on a beaucoup de mal à communiquer en
fait parce qu'on n'a pas les budgets des
grandes chaînes de magasins et la nuit
de la déco c'est vraiment fait pour ça
c'est pour donner une visibilité aux
petites boutiques de proximité pour
cette première participation plus de 250
internautes ont voté pour secret
d'intérieur parmi une centaine de
magasins une opération de communication
mais surtout solidaire on vend des dvd
piqueur pour au profit de mécénat
chirurgie cardiaque
donc ça c'était vraiment aussi très très
bien aimée qui en partant bien
participer puisque j'ai pu récolter 600
euros pour mécénat chirurgie cardiaque
une petite boutique comme moi je t'ai
j'étais assez fier et on remet ça
puisque le 19 mai on refait une nuit de
la déco et là ça va être sur le thème
les boutiques pour leur cinéma le
magasin affiche aujourd'hui un chiffre
d'affaires de 250 mille euros par an ce
trophée permet une reconnaissance
supplémentaire dans un secteur dominé
par les grandes enseignes